[Music]
if you want to improve health you have
to deal with more than just the
provision of medical care so a lot of
what medical care gets blamed for of
what we call the health system the
hospital the docks what we get blamed
for are things that we don't have direct
responsibility for in the US with very
very high mortality a higher than other
parts of the world and lots of reasons
for this for example
debt from gunshot wounds is included in
the mortality stats yet people who work
in healthcare are not the people who
actually kill people with guns
sometimes these statistics get all
warped that doesn't mean we shouldn't be
involved that doesn't mean we shouldn't
be a catalyst that we shouldn't be an
influencer that we shouldn't actually be
out there in the communities doing
things now if you get sick right and you
come to a hospital yeah we can take care
of you but the issues that determine
your health go way way beyond just the
provision of medical care it has to do
with lifestyle it has to do with social
circumstance it has to do with
environment your family situation where
you live if you're living in a very very
good neighborhood there's a lot of
research done on this with all of the
all of the facilities that you would
have in any top middle class upper
middle class neighborhood you will live
years longer than a person who lives in
a very very poor area in general so if I
want to improve your health I gotta make
sure that I have doctors and nurses are
settled to provide a medical care to you
but I've also got to figure out how to
walk on all of these other things how do
I for example make sure that there is
not lead in the house that you live in
or in the apartment building we had kids
living in homes and it still goes on and
many of the buildings in New York City
and elsewhere where the radiators in the
homes were painted with lead paint well
let pipes now I can have the doctor go
to that apartment every month and treat
that kid but unless I changed the paint
or change the pipe or get rid of the
radiator or cover up the radiator having
a doctor go there every month doesn't
necessarily overall improve health so I
know somebody in the last two days that
was at the hospital
had an occurrence in the hospital in one
of our hospitals course home our
hospital sent a nutritionist to the home
that nutritionist sat down with that
person for a couple of hours explained
to him how they should be eating as
person there was a weight issue not
substantial but there was a weight issue
that was a high blood pressure issue so
they explained diet they then offered to
come to the home and teach the person
how to cook those foods that they that
would be more appropriate to improve
health that's how we improve health the
hospital did its thing but if you don't
follow up and do those other things that
person will be back in hospital again
[Music]